hey youtubers it's Charlie so this is
gonna be my agents of shield episode 6
video we actually get to see a couple
big comic book characters we saw at the
Marcus scarlotti whiplash who's from the
Iron Man comics and we got to meet
Ward's brother not necessarily a comic
book character even though they did put
the alien writting storyline on the back
burner so to speak we did get a big WTF
at the end if you didn't recognize him
he was Brian van Holt from Cougar Town
so I did laugh my way through that end
credits scene just a little bit I know I
also promised to do a Q&A about the big
Marvel phase 3 announcement so I'll
answer a bunch of questions after I get
through shield stuff hello to any new
people if you just found me for the
first time I do agents of shield videos
every week so if you haven't already be
sure to subscribe to get everything
we're approaching the mid-season finale
and there will be some Avengers
crossovers next year
careful for spoilers if you're not
caught up on shield yet but starting
with top five moments number five Hydra
is taking shots at shield so the person
they're using to masqueraded shield is
Marcus scarlotti from the comics they
change his character just a little bit
way way back in the really old Iron Man
comics he worked at Stark Industries and
then eventually became a mercenary so
this is the version were saying
basically like a modern-day version of
the mercenary version of that whiplash
most of the people I saw in my Twitter
feed were just calling a mohawk person
the big twist at the end was that the
person on TV who was offering them safe
haven and Bruges was actually a Hydra
agent his grandfather was the one who
developed those Hydra weapons they were
using or the original versions of it
number four Fitzsimmons versus Fitz Mac
so Fitz
Simmons and Mac were the ones that
figured out that Vincent Becker's was
like the really really old Hydra agent
that developed those weapons
Julian Becker's is the character that we
saw in Bruges he's like one of the
political leaders there that was
offering them safe haven which turned
out to be a trap
I guess Hydra runs in their family
figuring that out was just the smallest
part of the lab scenes it was really all
about the v Simmons reunion and how
that's totally not working out which is
a little heartbreaking I am totally
digging Mac right now he is like the
obi-wan Kenobi of this episode so he
tells Simmons Fitz is a new Fitz he's
not the Fitz that you knew him as just
get used to it earlier Fitz also said
the same thing to Jemma pretty much you
know you're different
not bad different just different it will
take some time to get used to it but I
think they'll be able to
like I don't think that the Fitzsimmons
relationship is forever broken did you
notice when she came in with the coffee
like Fitz is already pouring it like
that used to be their routine so that
was a little bit sad to see because you
could see she kind of realized oh this
isn't gonna be happening anymore I think
they just need to find a new shared
ritual and that'll just be the start of
their new relationship whatever that
ends up looking like what about that
last scene when Ward walked out Simmons
is gonna cut a not only did he
harm Fitz he broke their relationship
either way there is a light at the end
of the tunnel I think that Mack is gonna
be like the intermediary between Fitz
and Simmons he'll translate for Fitz and
for Simmons both ways number three the
ward montage this was all about lying
liars and the lies that they tell didn't
you just love the way they bounce back
and forth in the scenes between Ward's
brother and Coulson and Skye and ward
just in terms of what's going on I think
that they're both liars and they're both
lying like Ward is a liar he continues
to lie words brother wolf in sheep's
clothing probably lying through his
teeth too and don't worry I don't think
the Coulson was buying any of his
it's really hard to tell with
Coulson he keeps such a straight face he
must be amazing at poker
that being said based on the trade that
Coulson makes at the end the senator
Ward's brother I think called off the
all-out attack that he planned in the
beginning of the episode he did
specifically call out Hydra at the end I
don't know if he's gonna turn out to be
Hydra he might just be playing both
sides part of the idea that they've
teased in a lot of the Marvel movies and
agents of shield so far is that not all
evil people are Hydra like regular
people can be just as evil as really big
villains like the Red Skull that might
be what Ward's brother is although it
would be freakin crazy if he turned out
to be someone in disguise
Tom to Kate really big actor so I am
surprised that they got him but shield
and Marvel ABC big networks so it's a
little bit easier for them to get big
talent
adrianne palicki is just another great
example of that just to address wards
escape at the end I think they were
teasing that like he's gonna go on the
run now it was all happening while the
senator was making that speech about
evil spreading I do think that Ward is
gonna continue to be a bit of a low-key
figure we're not gonna know whether he's
telling the truth or not I think he's
just gonna pursue this sky plot like
he's just gonna try and bring her to her
father he said it in one of their
earlier episodes he's not loyal to Hydra
he was only loyal to Garrett and now it
seems like he's loyal to
I won really funny thing though is that
Brett Dalton the actor that plays him
shaved that beard a long time ago so
anytime you see him with a beard in
episodes that's a fake beard it's not a
big deal but I just I laugh every time I
see it number two mockingbirds in
full-on Avengers gear so Bobby's been on
the team for a while we don't really
know how much time has passed since the
last episode but she's been living there
for a while now did you not love the
fact that she entered the episode
wearing a Star Wars t-shirt making a
Hawkeye reference and giving us our
whiplash call-out she was like a comic
book bomb just dropped on the episode
and when I say full on Avengers gear I'm
talking about the outfit she had at the
end of the episode it was a lot more
like Cobie Smulders Avengers outfit in
that movie she was actually in the
Avengers age of Ultron trailer from last
night too
if you didn't see it whosoever be he
worthy shall haveth apart whatever man
it's a trail it is much more than that
my friend
if I lift it to a get to the last guard
yes of course I will be fair but firmly
cool
I'm not even pulling are you on my team
just represent pull alright let's go oh
that's not a question I need answered
the handles imprinted whosoever is
carrying Thor's fingerprints is I think
the literal translation yes that's a
very interesting theory I have a simpler
one you're all not worthy I know I've
said mockingbirds does have the chance
to appear in an Avengers film that would
probably be Captain America 3 now which
is confirmed to be civil war the Bobby
Hunter scenes were probably some of the
most fun ones during the episode though
normally I'm not really down for a
relationship comedy stuff whenever
they're in action mode I do love
Avengers silly jokes and they do it
really well on agents of shield like
that very Joss Whedon type humor you saw
in the original Avengers movie they do a
really good job of replicating that with
this cast I don't think it would have
worked as well if Mae hadn't have been
the one with him Mae is like the
ultimate reaction shot like whenever
Bobby asked her if she ever talked to
her ex-husband which was another big WTF
first May's reaction was just hilarious
just that look she gave her but we did
not know that Mae used to be married
that's actually pretty big news now we
can start speculating on who that is
house and Bruce best continuous action
scene ever bobbi and Hunter definitely
make a great team I love their shared
action sequences like you can tell
they're very much in sync even though
they're not together anymore they'll
probably start hooking up again pretty
soon as long as Adrianne Palicki stays
on the show and of course my number one
WTF moment the end credits scene so like
I said if you didn't recognize him he's
Brian van Holt from Cougar Town he
played an idiot on that show so I
laughed so hard when he walked into that
tattoo parlor they just listed him as
stranger on IMDB so we're not gonna find
out who he is for a little while he was
getting tattoos of the cream app or
whatever it is but he was guiding the
artists hand like that's why he put his
hand over the needle it did look like he
was getting some sort of sick pleasure
from it Coulson on the other hand does
not get pleasure from it it's more of a
compulsion for him it does make you feel
like his character this Brian van Holt
character is gonna turn out to be evil
he's probably the one that carved the
drawing on the back of that painting
either way it was a nice tease that's
gonna lead us into the mid-season finale
so we're only a couple up
so it's away from that and I think it's
gonna involve some big definer moment we
know that hydras already weaponized it
like they have those working weapons
what we really need now is another scene
between Skye's father and dr. Whitehall
operating the obelisk like doing
something really crazy with it
either way let me know what was your
favorite moment from the episode and
what do you think is gonna be going on
between Ward and his brother the senator
like that is very big question mark
right now overall I gave the episode a
solid B I love the way they introduced
some of these new characters Tom decay
was awesome Brian van Holt really
awesome as a big question mark mystery
person although it was a little bit
funny just seeing him go from being an
idiot on Cougar Town to being this crazy
evil looking person I was happy they
spent more time developing the ward
character but we haven't spent a lot of
time with him we're almost the
mid-season finale
they've got to explain what they're
gonna do with that character for the
rest of the season I've already said a
whole lot about Mockingbird she's
amazing Adrianne Palicki so much fun
like she said still looking for a home I
feel like that's a wink for her just
bouncing around from movie to movie but
she's just teasing us the audience that
you know I don't know if I'm gonna stay
here forever or not speaking of
questions I know I promised to do Q&A
for the big Marvel and ask for the other
day so I'm just gonna blank it answer
all the biggest questions that you guys
have right now so just going down the
line we'll start with Civil War a lot of
people asking how they're gonna do this
without spider-man
so spider-man was really key to the
identity aspect of Civil War they're not
going with that it's gonna be more about
who reports to who like agencies
reporting to agencies chain of command
type stuff so Captain America Iron Man
both gonna be feuding quite a bit that
aspect of the story will stay the same
largely thematically it'll be a
superhero against superhero with
villains swirling around in the
background because they're introducing
Black Panthers costume for the first
time they obviously have to introduce
Black Panther Chadwick Boseman which is
gonna be amazing I think we're gonna see
Secret Avengers in Captain America 3
Captain America will like have his own
team of superheroes
I think they'll use that to introduce a
lot of the alternate Avengers that will
see an infinity war for those that are
asking yes Marvel has been teasing an
alternate Avengers roster by the time we
get to the end of age of Ultron that
doesn't mean that all the Avengers will
be different it just means the team we
have right now will not continue to
exist together all the different
subtitles to these movies like thor
ragnarok kind
explain why that is the Marvel Universe
being thrown into complete chaos so just
look forward to definitely Black Panther
confirmed for Captain America maybe that
Captain Marvel character too they
haven't cast Carol Danvers yet I
actually jumped at her her movie isn't
happening too much later although it's
happening before Wonder Woman so Marvel
will have a female lead superhero film
before DC does it will be Carol Danvers
right now top picks are Emily Blunt she
was originally supposed to be Black
Widow but it just didn't work out so
they gave it to Scarlett Johansson just
think about that Emily Blunt was
originally going to be one of the first
female Avengers Katee Sackhoff is also a
big second pick moving on Doctor Strange
also potential to show up in that
Captain America film in the small cameo
a lot of that just depends on when
Benedict Cumberbatch science his
contract until he does they're not gonna
do anything with that character they
still have some time they're in
pre-production for Captain America 3
they haven't started shooting it yet but
until Marvel owns his soul they can't do
anything with him which is funny because
Doctor Strange sold his soul in the
comics next up is guardians of the
galaxy 2 they didn't announce anything
about this because James Gunn is still
on vacation they're in pre-production
for that movie we will see fan OHS again
but they're gonna go to a different part
of space a big part of the plot will be
Peter Quill's father I'm not planning on
seeing more infinity gems but it is
totally possible because Fanus is in the
movie I've already done a video about
stories that I think they should do for
that movie so I'll add a link in the
description if you guys want to learn
more about that next up is Thor Ragnarok
I know everyone's really excited about
this one even though the movies coming
out two years after Avengers 2 the
events of the movie will pick up right
after Avengers 2 so it's not gonna be
like a real time thing like they've done
in the past so whenever we see Thor in
Thor 3 he will have just left whatever's
been going on in Avengers 2 this is the
movie that's gonna deal with what Loki
has been doing while he's been
masquerading as Odin and everyone was
wondering what happened to Odin at the
end of dark world if you believe Anthony
Hopkins he's dead Anthony Hopkins just
said he didn't want to do more Marvel
movies so they weren't gonna use the
character again that's just an actor
saying something offhandedly in an
interview so do not pay attention to it
it will be a big Thor Loki movie with
Fire Lord Serdar but Ragnarok is a big
storyline from the comics so if you want
to learn more about that just read that
comic
it's really interesting I'm not gonna
spoil it here next up we have black
panther with chadwick boseman I am
totally stoked about postman being Black
Panther so far it seems like based on
the comics all you guys are - I think it
lends a lot of credence to the theories
that Andy Serkis is playing Ulysses Klaw
in Avengers 2 and they'll do the plot
where he steals a bunch of vibranium
from Wakanda in terms of villains for
that movie they'll probably just go with
some of the classic villains or if they
have any existing villains like Ulysses
Klaw they'll probably use them a lot of
it just depends on what they do in the
other Marvel films but they probably
will introduce a new big villain then we
move into Avengers infinity war which is
being split into two films you can think
of it as like infinity quest and then
the Infinity Gauntlet storyline so danos
at some point is probably going to
assemble the gauntlet
we saw the teaser with him wearing the
gauntlet with all the gems in it I was
actually really surprised that they
showed that off at the Marvel event that
was pretty crazy the second half of the
film will probably be the Avengers
fixing whatever Thanos does like getting
the gauntlet off of his hand I'm really
interested to see if they introduced the
cosmic idea of death like if they
introduced that character in the Marvel
Universe or if they go a different route
one of the big things that Kevin Feige
was clear on is that infinity war will
be a crossover event crossover in the
grand tradition of comics so I think
it'll be a big Guardians crossover
that'll be the point of crossover
because Thanos is one of the shared
characters that they have between those
two franchises either way Infinity
Gauntlet you guys should totally read
that comic next up is Captain Marvel
with Carol Danvers just like black
panther I think that they're gonna
introduce the character in a cameo in a
previous film probably Captain America 3
it is possible they could wait till
Avengers infinity war as far as we know
she's not gonna be in guardians - James
Gunn already said that they're not gonna
have more human characters in that movie
and moving on last one Inhumans movie
this is actually a bit interesting
because we have not seen any trace of
the Inhumans in the Marvel Universe
although it kind of looks like that's
what they're teasing on agents of shield
right now with all the alien writing we
know it's a map it could be a map to
Attilan city of the Inhumans but I do
think that we'll see the Inhumans for
the first time officially inside a movie
there's no way they're gonna wait till
the Inhumans movie to introduce the
Inhumans so they could either show up in
Avengers 3 they could show up in Captain
America 3 any of the other
major Avenger movies I know there's no
new Iron Man movie that's been announced
Robert Downey jr. said he's open to Iron
Man for they're really just waiting for
the right script let me know how you
feel about all this though Marvel
dropped some serious bombs but I'll be
doing a bunch more videos as we go
forward so be sure to subscribe to get
everything if you have anything
specifically you want to talk about or
any special movies just let me know I'm
totally happy to do them right now
though click here to learn more about
that Marvel announcement and Doctor
Strange and click here for last week's
agents of shield thank you so much for
watching let's all high-five I will see
you guys tonight
you